j'avais préparé leur interview donc je
vais vous donner je vais vous dire ce
qu'on a pour Rock et Roca l'état dans
lequel a été retrouvé le chien n'a rien
à voir avec eux ils disent que ils sont
toujours très bien occupés ils disent
concernant les traces d'acide et de
cigarettes et les coûts avec une
matractécopique dont on parlait il nie
complètement l'effet assure que les
policiers n'ont rien trouvé pendant leur
perquisition
concernant la bosse sur la tête du chien
Texas donc la chienne voilà qui
s'appelle hop maintenant je serai tomber
dans les escaliers du loft et ce serait
la raison pour laquelle Texas avait une
bosse sur la tête et sans les papiers il
ne pouvaient pas l'amener chez le
vétérinaire un vétérinaire leur a
conseillé d'acheter une crème d'arnica
et de traiter le chien pendant une
semaine